في هذه الحرب نحن نقف معا وبقوه هكذا بدا
المشهد في تل ابيب قبل نحو 100 يوم وهكذا
بدا التوحد خلف القياده السياسيه لاداره
الحرب على غزه لكن بعد 100 يوم يظهر
الوزير بحكومه الحرب بيني جانس في مظاهره
حاشده بتل ابيب تعارض الحكومه وتهاجم
تعاطيها مع ملف الاسرى الاسرائيليين في
غزه كان انضمام بني جانس لحكومه الطوارئ
عقب الس من اكتوبر رغم معارضته السابقه
لنتنياهو نقطه قوه كبيره للاخير ربما ظن
جانس وغيره ان السابع من اكتوبر رغم
مرارته سيذي خلافات ما قبله وخاصه بشان
تعديلات نتنياهو القضائيه لكن الايام
المئه اللاحقه كانت كفيله بتفجير خلافات
حاده بل صراعات داخل حكومه الطوارئ ومجلس
الحرب اشتراك جانس في التظاهر بدا منسجما
ومتزامن مع انباء مشاح حناه لافته داخل
مجلس الحرب حيث منع نتنياهو مدير مكتب
وزير دفاعه يواف جالانت من حضور جلسه
الجمعه ما اغضب جالنت الذي اتهم نتنياهو
بالتشويش على عمله منسحبا من الجلسه لمده
ساعه قبل ان يعود لاحقا وهي مواقف غير
مسبوقه وفق متابعين وخاصه في زمن الحرب
قبل اسبوع وقع اشتباك كلامي بين وزير
الدفاع جالنت ووزير الامن القومي ايتمار
بنفير لم يكن المشهد جديدا بعد ثلاثه اشهر
مريره من الحرب لكن وزيره المواصلات ميري
ريجيف اخرجت في سخريه لاذعه كيس فشار
قائله لقد بدات المسرحيه فضلا عما تعرض له
من قبل رئيس الاركان هيرتس هاليفي من هجوم
قاسن شنه وزراء اليمين المتطرف بسبب تشكيل
لجنه للتحقيق فيما جرى صباح السابع من
اكتوبر الخلافات الحاده وضبابيه الرؤيه
تشمل مساله الاسرى وملف ما بعد الحرب وهو
العنوان الذي فجر وحده اكثر من جلسه لمجلس
الحرب حاولت الانعقاد لمناقشته مواقف باتت
تتكرر على نحو لافت ويصاحبها اتهامات
لنتنياهو بانها من تدبيره لكن لماذا يسمح
نتنياهو بالنيل من قادته العسكريين في زمن
الحرب يسود اعتقاد واسع ان بنيامين
نتنياهو يدير هذه الحرب بدوافع سياسيه
شخصيه ولا يتهمه خصومه بالاخفاق فقط في
تحقيق اي هدف مما حدده لها بل بالوقوع
ايضا رهينه لوزراء اليمين المتطرف وخاصه
بنفير و سموتريتش فهو يشتري بقاءهما
بجواره باي ثمن كي لا تنهار الحكومه التي
تشير استطلاعات راي كثيره لتراجع شعبيته
على راسها وهو ايضا يواصل الحرب لا يلوي
على شيء ولو كان سلامه الاسرى
الاسرائيليين في غزه رغم كل تحذيرات حماس
ورغم الضغوط المتصاعده من العائلات لانه
يوقن وفق خصومه ان هايه الحرب تعني نهايته
سياسيا على الاقل